good morning good afternoon and good
evening to everyone thank you for
joining the symposium and thank you for
joining today's talk um
unfortunately i'm really sorry but i
can't be there in person uh
unfortunately the the way time zones
work it's not so great but i hope that
uh this video presentation will be
interesting and exciting to you and of
course at the very end i'm happy to take
questions uh by you know text by email
by by chat or or any other way so today
i'll be talking about the origin and
evolution of biopolymer and
non-biopolymer based compartments
so first of all i'd like to start with a
little bit of a self-introduction so i
actually did my bachelor's degree at
caltech where i studied chemistry and
business economics and management and
part of my research involved studying
chloroplast protein expression
crystallography as well as using mass
spectrometry to study pulmonary
surfactant lipids
next i moved to harvard where i did my
phd and i studied mostly rna i studied
rna sequencing technologies specifically
used for non-coding rna quantification
and i also studied ways which rna could
polymerize and replicate without using
enzymes so-called nonzen enzymatic rna
polymerization
because i had so much experience working
with all of these different biomolecules
lipids proteins nucleic acids i got
really interested in
how exactly those biomolecules emerged
and evolved in the first place and that
led me to my current position so since
2017 i've been a researcher at the earth
life science institute at tokyo tech
institute of technology and also since
2019 i've been an affiliated scientist
at blue marble space institute of
science
and since then uh at lc i've been
working on a variety of different topics
related to
origin of life and astrobiology but also
related to other interesting topics such
as dna liquid crystals or continuing
with some rna sequencing technology work
so uh before i get into today's main
part of the talk i'm going to turn off
my camera in case there's uh
you know if in case the the
the portrait interferes or blocks some
of the content
so today i'd like to go through four
different you know minor topics so
in case you aren't familiar with uh what
exactly is astrobiology especially in
the eyes of a prebiotic chemist
i want to introduce and give maybe a
little bit of a review about primitive
cells and what they might look like and
then give two short case studies in
origins of life research featuring
different polymers one is from a
biopolymer based background one is from
a non-biopolymer-based background so
hopefully you can see the similarities
and differences of those sequences and
those systems that we study and finally
i want to
introduce some opportunities for
students and researchers to participate
in astrobiology research both at elsi my
current affiliation as well as outside
of lc
so what what exactly is astrobiology i
think many people have different um
concepts of what exactly is astrobiology
for example if you take a look at the
word astrobiology you would think that
it's the intersection of astronomy and
life science
and basically it is
astrobiology takes
um you know concepts from astronomy
takes concepts from life science and
what astrobiology is encompasses many
different things so what what i think
and from a prebiotic chemist perspective
what i think astrobiology research
encompasses includes
for example the active search for life
in space this is you know searching for
current life or former life and often
this is through missions for example in
japan there's a hayabusa2 mission which
went to get samples from the asteroid
called dugu it recently returned to
earth a couple years ago and they're
studying those
samples right now and in a few years
jaxa will be sending a mission to one of
the martian moons uh and to study uh
kind of the structure of the martian
moons and bring that uh those samples
back so that's one aspect
another aspect is searching for
habitable planets in space so for
example searching for exoplanets probing
the habitability of extraterrestrial
bodies and this can be done for example
through space-based telescopes like the
james webb
space telescope shown on the left or
through these radio telescopes that are
on earth and this is alma on the right
next we also have the active search for
the origin of planets earth and life on
earth and so this includes the search
for organisms that live in extreme
environments which might provide a
window into what life was like back on
early earth as well as research on
planetary and geological formation and
this also involves studying you know
areas of the earth which might simulate
areas
that one could find on other planets
and these three last topics are
something i my research has a hand in so
the search for how to make synthetic
living systems in the lab how primitive
chemist chemicals assembled in the
primitive life and finally how this
primitive life evolved into modern life
so this is the the topics that i'm
personally researching uh it's part of
this you know subfield of astrobiology
which is origins of life field and it's
a really small part of the field but
extensive collaboration is really
essential in order to really understand
aspects of the origin of life and
especially collaboration with different
types of researchers and even
researchers or you know those with an
engineering background or people from
non-scientific backgrounds is really
essential
so
coming from kind of a biochemistry or or
a biology background i'm sure many of
you are really interested in how the
cell works what the structure is and so
you know this is a simplistic cartoon of
the cell but essentially it's built up
of many complex parts
and researchers have really
had a lot of success understanding
many of the structures and what they do
and what they
what they're made to do or maybe during
diseases when they have trouble
um and we've learned a lot about the
cell in the last 20 30 50 years but
there's still many unanswered questions
and one of these big unanswered
questions is
what did the first cells look like how
did these first cells function
and some researchers believe that
something like a more primitive type
cell existed on early earth some people
call this a protocell
and maybe this included some type of
compartment boundary some type of
replicating genetic system
housed you know catalysts like enzymes
or primitive enzymes and then also could
participate in evolution growth and
division and so
one way to think about origins of life
research is to we want to understand how
the chemicals on early earth in the
prebiotic soup if you will
assembled into these primitive
compartments or protocells and how these
protocells function and eventually
evolved into modern cells
and specifically
if we think about this a non-biomolecule
or non-biopolymer based
prebiotic soup
how could this eventually assemble and
evolve into a biomolecule or a
biopolymer based
modern cell is a really interesting and
big question
and in order to do this one
way is to try to see or understand what
this primitive cell looked like what it
could do and we can approach this in two
ways going from the bottom up building a
primitive compartment using these um
non-biomolecules available on earlier
through prebiotic chemistry or we can go
from the top down taking what we know
about biology and kind of working
backwards to see
what you know minimal what minimized
functions or what minimized types of
cells could have existed so what i like
to say is kind of we want to build this
primitive compartment from both
directions
and so let's say going from uh top down
i think this is something that uh most
more more of you in this audience are
familiar with
um let's see how this primitive cell
would have looked like if we work
backwards from a modern cell and
forgive the simplicity of this cartoon
as well this is
you know one of the processes we see in
the modern cell it's as you know the
central dogma
and these are composed of different
processes made up of biopolymers and
biomolecules and catalyzed by
biomolecules so what we want to know is
on early earth or in an early cell which
of these processes were still essential
so
for example it's very likely that
proteins did not exist on early earth
they're too large they're
they're folding is too difficult to have
achieved
and also it's very likely that our dna
couldn't have existed really on an early
earth so this leads many to
postulate that the first cells on early
earth contain rna and this is
specifically
um leads to a uh
origin of life hypothesis which suggests
that rna is the first and most important
biomolecule of life
this hypothesis is called the rna world
hypothesis and it postulates that
because rna can store and pass down
genetic information
because it's similar in structure to dna
and also because rna can fold into
specific structures that can catalyze
chemical processes
in the form of ribozymes similar to
proteins that rna was the first and most
important biomolecule on early earth and
while there's been a lot of research
in this
field and a lot of progress has been
made
there's still a number of outstanding
questions
in the rna world for example how the rna
could be synthesized how it polymer
polymerizes how it's prevented from
hydrolyzing there's many questions that
researchers are answering to this day
and there are also hypotheses that rna
wasn't the only biomolecule that existed
on early earth for example
some researchers have postulated that
dna and rna could have
coexisted on early earth maybe in a
hybrid form
and based on the structure of the
ribosome as we know it today it's also
been postulated that perhaps rna and
peptides co-evolved so instead of a
purely rna world you might have had
something like an rna peptide or an rna
protein world
and so what all this is just saying is
that we're not exactly sure exactly
what was in this early cell and it's
plausible that all of these or even more
types of molecules existed in or around
these cells so let's assume from now on
that we have access to a number of
different types of biomolecules for
building this primitive cell
the next thing i want to focus on is
this boundary so this boundary is really
important and defines a cell from other
cells specifically it makes the cell
defined as a compartment and
compartments are really essential to
origins of life
compartments segregate and con
concentrate reactants they promote
chemical reactions
promote evolution prevent fusion of
genetic materials many many different
important functions on early earth
and
you know modern cells they're made up
mostly of a phospholipid membrane that's
the boundary it's been postulated that
perhaps early cells that are membrane
bound were made up of fatty acids rather
than phospholipids because they're much
easier to synthesize
using prebiotic chemistry
and what's available back on early earth
due to there being only one chain rather
than two
and so one further question is that
can you actually make a boundary that's
even simpler than fatty acids that that
doesn't even require that type of
bilayer and so what we're interested in
is seeing whether such types of
compartments could have existed and
whether they could form or function as
early cells or protocells
so
one way is through liquid liquid phase
separation for those who are familiar
with this um you might have heard about
this if you haven't it's actually one
way to form droplets
in solution these droplets are are
membraneless but they're still liquid
and they provide compartmentalization
without a membrane they allow exchange
of molecules between phases and in fact
they're present in modern biology so
there's a phenomenon called biological
phase separation which results in
formation of membraneless organelles in
the cell these organelles you know there
are some some of them are called for
example
nuage granules or stress granules maybe
chromatin is even considered one of
these and these are membraneless
organelles in the cell that are really
important for controlling biological
processes and it's been postulated that
because
you know most cells or almost all cells
have this
type of face separation
inside to make these membraneless
organelles that perhaps they're an
ancient invention and that phase
separation was also used to make
compartments on early earth
and so here let me move on to a couple
case studies of origins of life research
and let me start with the biopolymer
case so this is a case study on
primitive liquid crystal coaster rates
so you might have heard of liquid
crystals before they're present in
tvs or displays
and in fact you can actually make liquid
crystals out of dna so this is in
collaboration with
tommaso fraccia who's a researcher at
espci in paris
and so his previous research showed that
if you took short dna oligomers that
were self-complementary such as this
sequence shown here
they can actually form these duplexes
that aggregate end to end they stack
together and they form these long rods
and these rods will bundle together and
after drying after increasing the
concentration of the dna significantly
the structure that results is this
columnar liquid crystal structure
shown in this polarization micro
microscopy image on the right
so these structures are you know
somewhat liquid they have liquid and
solid characteristics and you can
visualize them through polarization
microscopy because of their super
molecular chirality
so we postulated that perhaps
it would be interesting if for example
a primitive compartment like one of
those phase separated systems could
actually house one of these liquid
crystal structures because they've shown
the ability to affect electrochemistry
or regio chemistry or regioselectivity
so what we did was we knew that
you know when nucleic acids like dna
and when peptides
like cationic peptides are mixed and
bind together they actually can form
these liquid liquid phase separated
structures so we took pll polylysine
about 250 residues long
polydisperse mixed it with high
concentrations of this dna ligamer
and we were able to find conditions in
which these
structures these nice membraneless
droplets or coastervates co-localized
with this dna crystal liquid crystal
structure shown on the bottoms through
the polarization microscopy so we we
believe that this dna liquid crystal
structure is formed through this
end-to-end stacking interaction of dna
and we actually found that these
structures the co-localized structure of
the liquid crystal coast survey only
exists in a very narrow range of
salinity for example when we varied the
salinity we found that at low
concentrations of sodium chloride
precipitation occurred whereas at higher
concentrations of sodium chloride only
droplets formed without liquid crystal
characteristics
or no droplets could form at all and we
believe that this is because
the ionic strength of the solution is
really important for this interaction if
there's lower amounts of salt the
peptide dna binding interaction may be
too strong forming precipitation or
solid-like particles whereas at higher
salt concentrations it
makes these structures these
interactions between the peptide and the
dna weaker suggesting that you know when
when the peptide and dna can no longer
interact for example at one molar sodium
chloride these droplets can't form as
well
we next wanted to hypothesize test our
hypothesis
uh as to whether this end-to-end
interaction is indeed what's forming
these liquid crystal structures so we
did the same experiment but with a
slightly different dna sequence this
time we included a 2t base overhang so
that this stacking process could not
occur
and we found that through all of the
different conditions we tested
in no
single case did we find liquid crystal
structures we did find many
conditions where these droplets could
form these phase separated droplets
could form but liquid crystals could not
be observed and this shows that this
end-to-end stacking interaction is
really essential for these liquid
crystals to form
we then next wanted to study the um
what happens if we subjected these
liquid crystal coaster rates to
processes or environmental processes
that might have existed on earlier so
one of them is dehydration
it's been proposed that dehydration
could be one way to
you know effect
different chemical reactions on early
earth you'll see this in the second part
as well and so we subjected these
systems to drying and so what you see
here is that throughout the drying
process
you can see these structures go from
these solid-like structures
transitioning to these
liquid crystal
coaster rate like structures to just a
simple coastervate and then to
a disassembled structure i'll play this
video again and we believe this is the
case because similar to the salinity
titration
dehydrating the solution actually up
concentrates the sodium chloride in the
solution perhaps which suggests that the
this phase transition follows a similar
phase transition as what we observed in
the sodium chloride titration case
next we started again and we wanted to
see the
reaction of when we heated these samples
so
we actually heated these samples up to
about 60 degrees and we can see a
transition from
this solid-like structure to a liquid
crystal coaster rate structure
furthermore further heating resulted in
disassembly of these liquid crystal
structures
resulting only in these non-liquid
crystal coaster rates
and then upon decreasing the temperature
we noticed that at 40 degrees on the way
down these liquid crystal classic rates
started to pop up again and we saw a few
different types of liquid crystal
coastal rates but also we saw that the
the population was also heterogeneous
some of them were still
you know typical droplets without liquid
crystal characteristics some of them had
liquid crystals inside
and we found that upon decreasing at
further to about 10 degrees that almost
all of these droplets
reconstituted this
liquid crystal character if we compare
between these before and after heating
the structures are pretty different and
we think that this is because this
heating process is basically akin to an
annealing process and of course
annealing is used to
allow in in you know dna and rna case to
allow the strands to bind completely to
find the most stable thermodynamic
conformation and we believe that in this
case perhaps the right figure here is
this is what the most stable
conformation is for the system
and so we believe that what's happening
is we have these liquid crystal
structures here
with increasing heat and salinity
you have these you know dna long dna
rods and teal and these
red strands of peptides bound together
the rods the dna rods are in this packed
hexagonal pattern upon increasing heat
and salinity these rods start to come
together
come apart
causing some structural change and then
the rods start to disassemble these into
um
you know d-stack and so you lose this
liquid crystal characteristic but you
retain the droplets and then further
increasing heat and salinity results in
disassembly of everything and you result
in no droplets
so for those who are interested in
learning more details some of these
studies are published you can see
one here
and one here as well i'd highly
encourage you to take a look if you're
interested in the details
next i'd like to um talk about our other
side non-biopolymer side of origins of
life research and here we focus on
membraneless polyester droplets
so here we're building from the bottom
up and you see
we're interested in building this
primitive compartment from the available
chemicals on early earth and it's
actually known that there's many ways by
which biomolecules could have formed on
early earth through you know meteorites
or atmospheric discharge
but we also find that together with
biomolecules that there's also many
non-biomolecules synthesized at the same
time for example murchison meteorite has
tons and tons of molecules inside
and if you analyze the miller ureaction
or atmospheric discharge
reaction products you also get tons and
tons of different molecules not all of
these are biomolecules
this suggests that non-biomolecules were
just as or even more abundant than
biomolecules on early earth so we're
interested in understanding how
biomolecules could catalyze how
non-biomolecules could have catalyzed
life's emergence
the system we like to use are alpha
hydroxy acids they're monomers similar
in structure to amino acids but with an
amine group that's replaced by a
hydroxyl group and what's great about
these is that through simple drying
these monomers can form polyester
polymers shown on the bottom here
so we wanted to create these polymers
these polyesters and see if they could
you know assemble into something useful
for the origin of life so we first took
monomer solutions and dried them to form
polyesters
and here's some mass spec data and you
can see that in all cases the um
monomers were able to polymerize into
polymers
let's zoom in again this is one of the
monomers lactic acid so you see that the
products are polydisperse they're not a
single product so you make many
different lengths of polyesters and so
you also form this gel-like structure so
this was
observed in almost all cases where all
of the polymer gel structures
were formed through
by these
poly disperse polyester products so we
took these gels and we dissolved them in
aqueous solution
and what we found was that droplets
could form they were turbid and we could
see these nice spherical droplets in
solution for almost all of these
structures
we actually took these droplets and we
acid them a bit further
so we first found that these droplets
could
you know encapsulate functional
superfold gfp
we also found that these droplets could
catalyze or scaffold the assembly of
some type of lipid structures around the
droplets
and finally we found that rna could
segregate and into and function in the
presence of these droplets
so one of the next questions we tried to
pursue was that you know only one type
of polyester droplet we found could it
could compartmentalize rna but these are
all neutral droplets that we studied
can other polyester droplets or droplets
made from other compositions
compartmentalize rna
and we
hypothesized that if we included a basic
alpha hydroxy acid something that could
be positively charged in solution
the droplets that contain this positive
residue could allow the rna with a
negative backbone to
segregate more strongly than than before
and indeed when we incorporated some
percentage of these cationic residues we
we still saw droplets
but we found that increasing the amount
of cationic residues actually resulted
in disassociation of the droplets and we
actually believe that for example
at really high concentrations of the
cationic residue it's very likely that
the droplets are too polar and too
soluble in water or they're too charged
and too soluble in water so they don't
form the droplets but at lower
percentages
of the cationic residue we still see
droplets and it's very likely that these
droplets are still cationic so it's
likely that the polyester formation is
governed by the total charge of this
mixture
and in fact we did find the ability for
these new novel you know cationic
droplets to segregate rna you can see
here on the bottom that the fluorescent
rna is really strongly segregated into
these droplets here and we found that
even increasing
the amount of
charged monomers
into a neutral polyester by only about
20 percent allowed polyesters which
originally went in the neutral form
couldn't segregate any rna to be able to
segregate some rna here shown in the
middle and the right
so even just a small amount can change
these structures
and so again if you're interested in
learning more details about
this study um or these studies some of
them have been published i would highly
encourage you to read some of these
papers here
um for more details so i'd like to of
course thank my funding sources a lot of
these funding sources came from japan
but also one from the french embassy in
japan
i'd like to thank some of my
collaborators that worked on this
project with me before especially irina
jim kuhan and tommaso both at elsie and
outside of lc
and i'd like to thank other
collaborators at lc and tokyo tech
especially chan and rihanna who recently
have been working with me on some other
really exciting projects related to
polyesters and also a lot of my
collaborators around the world for all
these projects as well it's been a great
experience and i hope to continue
working with everyone
so finally i'd like to give a few
you know
programs that you might be interested in
to get into astrobiology research so
blue marble space institute of science
has a young researcher program over the
summer if you're starting in university
or recently graduated and are interested
to do a virtual project over the summer
you can take a look there are different
projects of different types and
some are research based some are you
know outreach based some are
communication based
and so you can take a look at the
website shown here my main
affiliation elsie we're a research
institute located in tokyo
and we study the origin and evolution of
earth
planets and life on earth
and
here's some other pictures here we've
recently started a five-year integrated
masters phd program
and this program is open to both
domestic and international applicants
and you will be fully funded
if you're interested uh the next
deadline for fall 2022 enrollment is
mid-april you should visit this website
here uh hopefully you'll be interested
in this
and finally uh last year i was part of
the organizing team for a conference
called appgradcon which is astrobiology
graduate conference it's an annual
conference for students and postdocs in
or looking to get into astrobiology and
it's organized by students in post-docs
and it's a really great experience
especially if you've never done a formal
astrobiology or formal presentation it's
a really good
experience and opportunity graham
actually also was
one of the other speakers of this
session was a
an organizer back in the day as well
so the next edition is
online uh it's going to be held in
august and the abstract deadline is may
15th so if you're interested please
visit the website and the the new team
of organizers they've been doing a
really great job and i highly encourage
you to attend that
so thank you all for your time and
attention thank again thanks again to
the organizers for giving me this
opportunity i'm sorry again that i
couldn't be there live with you but i'm
very happy to take questions either by
email
or if you want to leave a comment on the
youtube i'm sure we can be in touch so
thank you again and i hope you enjoy the
rest of this meeting